hi I'm Liam Neeson and I'm going
undercover in the Internet
it's actually me I will find you and I
will respond to you has Liam Neeson
being considered for bond suspecting you
mean James Bond I was many many years
ago about 25 years ago I was considered
along with a lot of other actors so yes
I was considered for countenance ethnic
his lameness required to be in at least
one Superbowl commercial every year
absolutely
oh yeah you can comment but you can't
hide as Liam Neeson done and in
commercial voiceovers yes my early days
I did some and Belfast voiceovers for
radio commercials and stuff like that
I've narrated many many documentaries on
various subjects so yes I've done a few
dead Liam Neeson received weapons
training for the film unknown
I remember the film I don't remember a
huge amount of weapons certainly in the
tackle films yet I've worked with great
stunt guys my fight choreographer fat
Mark van LOH we've done 21 films
together he's quite an expert in weapons
handling and training so I've done quite
a bit yeah his limb Neeson as tough as
the eggs no I'm a pussycat really does
he care posted what's your relationship
with technology garlic glazed technology
me have you heard of this thing called
the Kindle I love this man's voice has
he done any audiobooks
I don't want and it was called how the
Irish saved civilization it's actually
me at age 9 Neeson began boxing lessons
of the All Saints youth club going on to
end
number of regional titles before
discontinuing retiring at age 17 I
discontinued boxing because I was
growing but there's a 17 I think it was
like 6 4 3 and the punch has really
started to hurt the training had to be
more intense and it was interfering with
scoob's studies and stuff so I hung up
that loves for good but I still train I
hit the heavy bag a lot it is actually
me he recalled the most embarrassing
moment in acting as swam relatively
early of his career he auditioned for
the role of Fezzik the Giant in the
Princess Bride 1987 director Rob Reiner
had a look of disgust on his face when
he realized that Neeson was only six
feet for Andre the Giant ended up
getting the role thankfully on to the
Giant because yeah I remember I met Rob
Reiner I find him to a credibly rude he
didn't even say hello when I walked into
the room he just turned to is casting a
system and when I asked for a giant what
I would hi to you
I said six-foot Floyd he's not a giant
thank you attended Queen's University of
Belfast for a short while to study
physics and computer science but flunked
right yeah right front died I was also
doing pure mathematics and I just lasted
a year it wasn't for me what fighting
style did Liam Neeson use and the movie
taken there was no fighting style it was
just it's above everything enter what's
up with Liam Neeson on a horse
remembering him oh yes on the palliative
Buster Scruggs I Drive a wagon and it
was a horse I rode and a Seth MacFarland
film called a million ways to die the
West
three years ago so it was the same horse
and the horse remembered me okay thank
you for your questions
have a good year